should you buy a home right now here are
some qualifying questions that I would
ask what's your current living situation
what's your current employment and
income situation and what's your current
savings situation if you're renting with
a secure job for a decent length of time
making predictable and stable income
with a solid Financial Foundation then
the sooner you can buy the better
regardless of rates now if you live at
home with a family rent free with a
brand new job in an industry that may be
heavily impacted by the economy and
inflation and you don't have good
savings you have tons of debt or just
bad money management overall then don't
buy it bonus question why do you want to
buy a house happiness trumps all I know
homeowners who aren't happy personally
or financially and I know renters who
are extremely happy personally and
extremely happy financially so
ultimately it depends but don't let the
media or outside influences stop you
from achieving your goals